I'm gonna be talking about logical
operators and short-circuit evaluation
and then some cool tricks you can do
with short-circuit evaluation so first
of all this is the logical and to
ampersand signs and this is the logical
or to pipe characters so if you have
something like this nested if statement
if num is more than five and then if num
is less than ten we're gonna console dot
log unicycle we can actually just use
the logical and instead of this nested
if statement so let's see that I'm gonna
get rid of this and this is gonna give
the same result if num is more than five
and num is less than ten console dot log
unicycles so just if the numbers between
five and ten we could also replace this
with the or sign or now it's if num is
more than five or num is less than ten
so either of those things could be true
to prep the console that long unicycle
and all numbers meet this criteria so
we'll always have a unicycle you can
never have too many unicycles okay now
let's talk about short circuit
evaluation short circuit evaluation
happens when conditionals use and or or
it means that the second argument is
evaluated only if the first argument is
not enough to determine the value of the
expression when the first argument of
the and function evaluates to false the
overall value must be false so it
doesn't have to evaluate the second
argument when the first argument of the
oral function evaluates to true the
overall value must be true so it doesn't
evaluate the second argument for
instance
so it evaluated the first one floor is
more than five but it didn't even
evaluate the second one once it found
out that this was false it didn't need
to even evaluate the the second part of
the conditional so that short-circuit
evaluation it just skips that part
completely you can actually use this for
some interesting things in JavaScript
for instance let me set something up for
you I pasted this code in here so we're
gonna set test to true and then we're
gonna create a function is true function
console dot log this is true far is
false is a function console that log
this is false so it says if test is true
well test is true so it's gonna run that
function so if test is true it runs the
function so if we run that yep it's
gonna say test is true but there's a way
this is the slow way to do it or the
more wordy way to do it with
short-circuit evaluation there's
actually a better way to do it that's a
little a little better let me show you
so in this short circuit evaluation we
just put test and and is true so if this
is true it's going to run the the next
one if the first argument is true our
method goes to the next argument which
can be a function so if Tess is not true
it won't run this function so let me
comment this out I'm gonna run that
again but it's still gonna say this is
true in the console because of this so
we made this whole if statement into one
line without even using the word if just
because of short-circuit evaluation let
me show you how you would do that with
the or operator okay here's the code
I've just put in here test equals false
if not test it test is false then run is
false so if we run that we can see yep
at the bottom says test is false
however the short-circuit way of doing
it is like this you're gonna put test or
is false so if this is true it's not
even gonna bother going to this because
it's the or operator and we're testing
this or this but if this is false then
it is going to go to the
function over here so if we run that and
you can see test is false test is false
it had the first test is false from here
and in the second test is false from
there okay another way that
short-circuit evaluation can be used is
to set a default value for a function
argument look at this function function
the same old foo and you're gonna put in
a name here so the name is going to
equal name or the name is gonna equal
bar that basically means if you don't
pass in a name there won't be anything
to assign to name so this will this
would be false and if this is false it's
gonna go to the next argument which is
bar if it's true it's going to assign
that to name so by putting or the two
lines like that which means or and
putting bar here you're saying a default
value so let's run that and see what
happens and you can see my best friend's
name is bar my best friend's name is Bo
so first it used the default and then it
uses what we assigned assigned here so
those are just a few things that you can
do with short-circuit evaluation well
thanks for watching my name is Bo Carnes
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good